that's right people I cut my hair that's
why I look like a boy now finally looks
like I got a penis not that I didn't
have one before I just um I can show you
right now if I wanted to but who
where is this conversation going
Oh what is going on you do been a while
since I've loved I missed you guys I
miss this interpersonal connection now
for me one of the hardest type of people
to deal with is a person with a lot of
baggage now as you get older and you
meet older people you will start to meet
a lot of people who just don't know how
to let [ __ ] go let it go let it go I
[ __ ] hate that song
got John Travolta over your can't even
pronounce the name of the lady who sang
the [ __ ] song [ __ ] the wickedly
talented adele dazeem [ __ ] so much
confidence your nephew gets it but back
to the point I am starting to get sick
of that [ __ ]
and you know why because you ever
noticed when you meet somebody with a
lot of baggage they like to blame you
for [ __ ] that happened in their past and
I'm talking about [ __ ] that you weren't
there for and to be straight up it
happens a lot in relationships you ever
just be sitting around you and doing
[ __ ]
and you're gonna suddenly look at your
says [ __ ] like you are just like Johnny
put the foot bit what first question
that comes to mind
who the [ __ ] is Johnny he never called
and guess what what ever I don't blame
me for [ __ ] that someone else did or did
not do that
I've never met [ __ ] to make a kitty I
want you roll over baggage you need you
deal with your emotions properly before
you start yelling at me for stuff that I
did not do and will never do Johnny
cheated on me again what your Jen
whatever she I don't cheat on women
and you know what difference I barely
got you what makes you think I suddenly
had the miraculous ability to get to
women when I barely got one have you
forgotten that you did not chase me I
chased you like you stole my lucky
charms and [ __ ]
she wasn't av how to bait you over to me
like a rare Pokemon either sabar is a
multiple tries you try to escape a [ __ ]
but I've got you I'm cheered like a
little Japanese anime girl yeah listen
you know what carrying baggage does it
prevents you from being happy you've got
to learn to let things that happen in
your past help you grow or you gotta let
it go cuz for the rest of your life you
will be
unhappy blaming people for issues that
you personally have not dealt with
rather than dealing with the situation
that you have with them listen even more
so than relationships does with baggage
are by far the worst
you know wise because they got something
called thug baggage where they assume
that everybody they see wants to fight
that I knew this thug back in high
school they used to get in a fight with
his twin brother that he said that only
he could see turns out he was fighting
with his own reflection Oh what is going
on YouTube
yes as you can see what I said before
the haircut his guns which means you
know I lost the weight that I wanted to
lose so I'm at my a happy point yes I am
but once again if you guys want to cop
your fresh here you can go ahead and
copy at go-for-broke apparel calm for
example such as this the nothing was
broke t I got my eyes on and of course
we got a lot of other fresh gear on the
side so go ahead and check that out
now remember buddy that it will be back
this Wednesday and I got some words of
encouragement and some funny [ __ ] and
some new tips for you so yes check it
out
Wednesday Wednesday Wednesday remember
if you guys want me to talk about
certain topics go ahead and go on my
Facebook fan page and leave me a message
and I will go ahead and read those and
you know what am i taking into
consideration it can be articles it
could be a topic something you're
dealing with a question I don't [ __ ]
care talk to me talk to me talk to me
because you know what your opinion
matters so yes family I will see you
guys this Wednesday and upcoming Sunday
peace the [ __ ] on out not for me one of
the hardest people put the pen down
right behind me spit it was a vlog you
need to fold now as you get older and
you tend to meet older people you will
rock there with the puns what the [ __ ]
was that
oh god John Travolta Travolta [ __ ] is
John Travolta John Travolta sounds like
a [ __ ] superhero [ __ ] I'm John
Travolta you need to deal with your
emotions properly before you start [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying before we get
we get in the fistfight